this is a production of cornell
university
yeah let's uh thanks everyone for
joining uh this is episode 12 this year
the cornell turf show our third season
uh
glad to have a former guest on dr raka
suave university nebraska lincoln those
of you who have listened or watched the
show in the past rock's been on chatting
uh
golf course turf and today we got him on
the sports uh the sports episode here
and we're gonna chat uh cultural
practices verification probably on
sports fields um probably talk about
safety a little bit there too so we're
excited for that conversation
uh but as always we'll uh
introduce frank here and frankie can get
us going this morning uh looking at some
weather trends and
as always a couple little tidbits uh
good pictures of note there we go yeah i
mean you love it right
everybody it's like the pandemic gave us
license to bring our little kids and
take them around i think there's going
to be a whole
burgeoning in 15 years of kids coming to
study this stuff because their parents
mothers and fathers took them to work
right nicole at baltimore you see her
kid raking the field at camden yards
every once in a while on our twitter
handle but here's the young man running
the auburn fields uh
bringing that's a that's a young one
there rock that's probably that's even
younger than than your grandchild which
i happen to have a picture of in a
minute as well but i thought you know
i'd start with what you taught me a long
time ago that and n was for knowledge in
nebraska
yeah and it's for knowledge and then
when you lay on your side because you've
had too much to drink it makes a z so
nobody disturbs
you all right and so thinking of
knowledge carl you're the man with the
data point for today what is it
yeah so as a prelude to our conversation
with rock here in a bit um this is a
case study we did a couple years ago
with one of our undergraduate students
uh rhys muller who is a member of the
soccer team on our soccer field our game
field here at cornell berman field
uh was pretty compacted on the sidelines
especially where players are kind of
warming up during the game maybe walking
around pacing around
so we did a little case study there we
took clegg firmness measurements uh
prior to
to errifying there uh and you can see
this blue line for those watching
um was outside of our preferred range so
a little bit firmer than we'd like and
actually getting close to what we
classify as high risk due to excess
firmness
uh why is that important on the sideline
of the field you know because we don't
have a whole lot of players running
around there well we know from chase
talking to chase straw in the past when
athletes are running towards the
sideline maybe trying to save a ball
when they step on a part of the field
that's noticeably different maybe firmer
or softer than the other parts of the
field they can't react to that right and
that's what can cause injuries when they
go from a safe firmness level on the
playing field to an excessively firm
sideline that becomes a safety issue so
what we did is um
we went in and did some verification
three-quarter inch tines
uh removed those cores top dressed with
some some sand and then a couple days
later came back and took new
measurements you can see there this
green line uh reduced our firmness right
down into the preferred range
actually a better standard deviation so
a more even firmness across that
sideline too uh so just a good example
of when we get uh
firmness readings that that indicate
maybe we have a safety issue using some
of these cultural practices can really
alleviate that get us back into a safe
range and in this case carl targeting
right i mean the beauty of this thing
was it took us a couple of hours all in
yeah to do the complete process uh and
actually you can see the guy in the
background there uh in one in this
picture uh actually doing the goal
mounts right in the penalty boxes and
you know when when money gets tight and
you can't do as many things on your
fields focus the resources you have
in the places uh that need it the most
right so carl let's get to the weather
and i think you know again
this is a common theme we've been having
we call it the roller coaster of the uh
up and down temperatures and you look at
uh on one day almost approaching a
record high
and
not five days later approaching a record
low and this gets to be uh really
difficult for scheduling things uh
putting up with where you know you're
growing a little bit and then you're not
growing so you're obviously getting some
heat into the system but overall it's
been cool uh for the past week we've
been right around normal maybe overall
two degrees above but lots of areas to
the west below normal and it looks like
after some warm-up weather immediately
here in the northeast we're going back
down into the 30s and 40s uh by
wednesday of next week so we're gonna
warm up and then head back down again
and by the time we see each other on the
sports show in a couple of weeks uh
we'll see how much we'll advance where
we are uh in that roller coaster so so
let me move to there we go and so
we start to now you know we're starting
to accumulate uh you know 100 or so
growing degree days or 80 to 100 or so
growing degree days since the middle of
march right so we're about a month in
we've maybe got you know 80 to 100. now
what are we forecasting moving forward
well you're seeing still
to the south you're going to do really
well but as you move up north you're
still saying you know teens 20s
30s so not still accumulating very much
and one of the reasons we use these on
these kinds of turf sports turf in
particular is maybe you've got some weed
issues you want to deal with maybe
there's broad leaf weeds surrounding
some of the fields hopefully it's not on
your field
and it's time now as we use that the
growing degree day model developed at
purdue uh sort of how it fits here where
we think we're time we're getting into
the esther form in the metropolitan new
york area we heard from nick mensheck on
the call yesterday the shortcut called
that dandelions are starting to bloom uh
on long island starting to see a few
peak ones here and there near buildings
uh in northern areas you start to get
them in urban areas where you got more
heat island effects but but on long
island across the board looks like
they're starting to bloom a little bit
now on the rainfall front everybody's
getting rainfall uh everybody's pretty
wet
and it looks like we are going to get a
little bit more and not dry out
significantly so this is a big part of
our discussion today with our guests
rocket swap professor gaswa from
university of nebraska lincoln and of
course now we bring in soil temperatures
we're still in the 40s you know not very
high not very conducive to growth and
this came up a couple of weeks ago
with our guest ben polymer who rock and
i were pals with the guy i think he
stole this quote from and i think he
attributed to him uh seed doesn't do you
any good in the bag
so it's time to get out and start
putting it out there
ben said that a couple of weeks ago and
i think it's a good reminder and so many
of you particularly in the springtime
are going to have lacrosse fields right
this you know because of the size of the
gold mount this thing is impossible
right so you get these kinds of surfaces
uh that it gets hard to grow anything in
and so
rock
this is the surprise uh thing for today
well you have to give me a little bit to
set you up here but but you know this is
something you did i think in the late
90s you didn't
nebraska in kansas and in iowa right
where you said screw it actually in the
narrative i think you say sports field
managers are so desperate to have any
cover they don't care what it is just
give us some grass cover so you did this
this i just showed you one table here
and draw your attention to what you did
right this was
incorporating bermuda grass seeded
bermuda grass its own rarity and you can
see the various types
of seed and bermuda that were available
you did them alone and with some
perennial rye grass but what i thought
was really interesting when you looked
at just overseeding with perennial rye
grass right uh you've got to 90 cover
right and
37
exposed soil by far
the highest exposed soil amount there
right so
um
what do you think about this now
20 years in
climate change
um
i got bermuda grass you know i'm
fighting in brooklyn uh at what point uh
does this become a viable
thing not just a a whim you guys uh put
together to do this have you followed up
on any of this let's start with this
conversation so that's a great question
and you know we still have some on very
high abused fields i don't even call
them high use anymore because they you
know especially our intramural fields
and
and things like that and then and as
well as some of these uh smaller
you know your rural communities where
they don't really have a budget they're
spending money on rye grass but our our
data shows the rye grass is pretty well
gone at the end of the season anyway but
we actually were developed we're able to
develop a little bit of thatch with a
little bit higher nitrogen not excessive
nitrogen
using bermuda as the over seed um i'm
not going to say the appearance is
spectacular because of course it goes it
goes dormant although the first year
seeding in bermuda grass stays green a
little bit longer that may be a density
thing environmental we're not really
sure why when did you see these in the
fall right
yeah we would see them in the fall or
actually uh late summer before we had
spring sports on whatever it was on on
the um like soccer and intramural
complex um you certainly wouldn't see
them any other time because so we'd see
them in summer those fields might be
getting used a little bit um and if they
were getting used a little bit we might
use a little bit of rye because bermuda
takes a little
longer to take hold and then you throw
in the climate change i mean clearly the
climate was was was changing back then
and climate is always changing but you
know but it wasn't on the trends it was
on the trends that we're on now
and and we weren't predicting anything
i'm not that visionary i'm not i'm not
frank rossi right so uh
so i wasn't that visionary but now i see
bermuda creeping further and further
north um
and and i wish it would be keychain more
than zoysia i know zoygins you know
they're growing it in indiana and other
locations i just don't think the
recovery and the growth potential of
zoysia is anywhere near even with the
new ones anywhere near bermuda grass and
seed is relatively cheap and i use
relatively it used to be it used to be
cheap
but but all seed is expensive now i i
saw rye grass go from a buck 20 a little
over a year ago to 330 340 now which is
ridiculous when you think about it but i
understand shortages and
supply chain and everything else well
and it's ridiculous when you think about
the places that continue to overseed
warm season grasses the rye grass seed
rates that they use
uh
that they got away with a buck a pound
that they're not gonna get away with at
five bucks a pound so listen let me move
on because the real topic of
conversation here was about soil stuff
right i want to talk to you about early
soil stuff we talked with doug last week
for lawns and grounds and sort of uh
really uh analyze the the need for
routine widespread verification and now
the caveat as i set up for you in our
weather is you know we got wet soil
conditions and when you go to our uh
safe sports fields website uh we have
this statement in there that says uh not
when it's too wet it's a goldilocks
right not too wet not too dry
here's you know maybe a couple of days
after normal rainfall on a moderately
well drawing soil you know you try to
caveat as best as you can so what i want
to go through and setting up our
conversation is one here's how we tell
people about it this is our safe sports
field website that we encourage uh
everybody to make their way to uh
and we've talked about this in the past
that cultivation is generally
short-lived uh high traffic areas may
need as much as six to eight uh
cultivations a year so that is obviously
something to consider in gold mounds and
and other you know high traffic areas on
soccer fields right this is the
traditional approach that we think about
uh getting out there and clarifying the
thing that i think is funny is that's a
good-looking tarp what the hell are they
here [ __ ] acting for i'm starting to
ask myself these questions i didn't ask
myself in the past rock but when things
get limited i'm like well what the hell
maybe you're overseeing but jesus is
there any place for the seed to go in
here so we start to think about okay
what are the various ways to approach
this and i know you and i have chatted
about this you've done some resources on
this i'm going to show you the one that
we have on our website but here's a
airway right a knife that goes in does
some
shattering uh these things wear out you
wonder about start to wonder about the
value of this device you you start to
look at the shattering uh versus the
cores and you see maybe you're impacting
a little bit more surface area than you
are when you're separating it by four or
five inches
on a field obviously there's a question
about in one pass how much good do you
do so i particularly wanted to indict
this
spoon airfication equipment rock uh and
i wanted to use our pal uh chase straw
he did some work with gerald henry when
he was a grad student there becky grubbs
who said texas now their colleagues at
texas bob carroll and van clank so this
was obviously done a little while ago
but it was reported in 2013 right so
a lot of people first off in their core
ideas half half the sports turf managers
are using this open spoon thing because
you go fast um and they were like well
is it any good right is is it any good
to use this open spoon so here's a a big
data table and the podcast people are
saved not having a look at this thing
but they measured things like
surface hardness penetration resistance
volumetric water ndvi which is turf
cover and you know all these
measurements and
only one year was there any effect on
surface hardness no other variable in
any of the three years no matter how
many times you did it was impacted by
open spool verification and they did it
up to four times a year so i went into
the results here and there's this really
interesting text there where they say
well you know our research says you may
need to do this more than four times a
year because we didn't start seeing a
benefit from this particular type of
verification unless you did it four
times but then you get yourself into the
compaction layer right you're doing it a
lot of times the same way
uh ricky showed this back in the day
rock even before you went to michigan
state he started looking at these
compaction pans when we got these new
devices right so along come these new
ways of doing things
and we you know like air 2g but we go
back to uh something that we put on our
website i know you've got a similar
resource this is cultivation practices
and their goals during playing seasons
right what are you trying to do so we're
in the season now obviously you can't do
drill and fill and it says you can't
slice things
small slicing and spiking that might
help with water infiltration so what i
want to do and chat with you about and i
got a couple of questions i'm going to
get to here here's the between seasons
if you don't have a spring sports season
you can you have some more options
available i thought i'd bring up the
grandpa picture
uh the proud grandma and grandpa picture
which is always a good way to introduce
you and ask you a couple of just simple
questions to get us started here
how do you know
what you need
to do
for errification
and how do you balance you know what
you're using with the tactics you know
you you can employ right how much the
field gets used where it gets used and
how you want to attack it so let's start
with the how do you know what you need
especially when your soil is really wet
here like it is uh in the northeast
right now what do you think
so both great questions and how do you
know what you need and i
this isn't a non-answer but it is a way
of looking at
you know the there's an art and a
science to what we do right
and this is where the art comes in
because conditions are different from
location to location and you know you
can have a rainfall at least in our
region you can have a rainfall and then
literally 10 miles away they get no rain
so certainly when we make these blanket
recommendations like you know we think
we can prescription this and we can to a
limited extent and then what and then
what's the end game and i think men are
you know clearly minor was ahead of his
time in a lot of ways and and um you
know he was always looking at well
what's your what's your goal what do you
want it to do are you trying to put seed
down and not really alleviate compaction
in that chart we use that same chart
when we do this training right um that
chart kind of shows that what's your
goal i mean do you want to get seed in
the ground do you want to shatter during
and you know they make a generic
recommendation there but at the same
time um they're not they're not saying
that this is the absolute way you have
to do it right so so you know what where
do you start is what what do you want to
do and you know sometimes if the soil is
wet and you go in there with any
cultivation device
it's going to make it worse
but if you need to get seed in the
ground certainly seed resting on the top
of muddy and compacted soil so then i
would go with a less i would probably
consider
short-term you know even though the
long-term benefits aren't good a slicer
or something like that where a very
superficial slicer or maybe even
something that dimples a little bit
knowing you're going to increase the
compaction but the less or the smaller
area of that tine and the less invasive
it is then you're going to compact
higher up
and which is going to get torn up by
players anyway right so in that scenario
with wetter soils let's go shallow
create a seed bed get the seed down
whether it's you know we were talking
about bermuda before whether it's
bermuda or rye because certainly those
are the the grasses of choice in these
scenarios where we need cover quickly so
just don't be as aggressive realizing
that this is this is a band-aid at best
until you can get in off-season or you
know you know an away stand or whatever
how however their practices are or
however their schedule scheduling goes
right and if it's a really
ultra high use field you know that the
scenario is they're putting seed out as
often as they're doing any kind of
cultivation right or maybe more so yeah
yeah so what about the open spoon did
you like my indictment because a lot of
people use this thing and maybe that's
just a limited study and they even said
the caveat there might be short-term
benefits but this is this was a
three-year study uh looks like doing it
four times a year would be enough
what are your thoughts when you get out
there talking to native soil fields and
you know they're doing this open spoon
stuff well you know when i saw that
article i was i i was questioning of
course i think we all were right you
know you know 50 of the people doing it
and so then i did a straw poll in our
region and
it was it was about 50 so i think that
data is pretty valid and that's a piece
of equipment that is quick you know
they're relatively inexpensive they're
relatively easy to maintain you know
there's a lot of good about that 100
but then so i was you know you called it
an indictment um then i started thinking
about how long-term core verification is
or how long-term any of our cultivation
technique i kind of went
it's short-term but it still has value
i wouldn't use it on a wet soil i mean
you know you know right i mean i thought
we've already kind of covered that but i
actually don't see that as a negative
i'm not comfortable with the idea that
if four didn't work then six might i i
wonder whether what direction you're
gonna know we don't really know that
right we just you know but it was three
years worth of data but if you know they
stuck to their guns and they did the
same study year after year after year
and they tracked it really really well
it was amazing to me how many things
weren't better than the control i know
well this you know brings me to the
point here when i show you this picture
of really good looking turf and you see
people taking six inch hollow tines out
of a decent soil that drains well it's
got good turf cover why do we do that
well you know i call that the farmer
mentality you know i got a tractor i
should use it right you know and i'm
going to go cultivate and we know
cultivation you know in farm fields
kills microbes and you know oxidizes
microbes and all that other stuff right
and i'm like so we're doing this and we
may not need it when you when you like
that picture you show there's an example
what's wrong with that turf and why are
you punching a hole in it
so but so here's what i get i'll give
you what i get well if i don't do it it
won't look like that the minute i stop
doing it it's going to fail and i will
be able to sleep
well if we'll go back to what you showed
at the very beginning that carl talked
about i've always thought about a a
field i don't care what it is it can be
field hockey we don't play that here but
you know lacrosse we don't play that
here either but you know it could be you
know american football or or the real
football right and we know the wear
areas we know the maintenance areas that
need the most help so so when i show a
picture of a field i often say think
about it like a golf course we manage
our greens differently than we manage
our tees then we manage our fairways and
we manage our rough right and in any
park system you're going to have areas
that are kind of like rough and areas
that are and just using a golf analogy
so why not manage these areas and i
really like what you showed there
because it's like here's where you know
you've got that transition for player
safety so that's a great catch right and
the reality of it is is that they're
running on the seal that you've really
maintained well and then they hit
basically concrete and you know that
can't be good for an athlete's feet or
everything else even even a weakened
warrior type athlete so treat those
areas differently and not even
i'll go so far to say frank you said
when budgets are tight you know you can
always spend money on something else so
let's do that routinely so maybe you go
into those areas you know four to six
times a year but do you really need to
you know let's get outside the hashes in
american football right let's get
outside the goal mouse and the center
you know
line for soccer but you know let's
always do the sidelines
if they haven't unfortunately put in i
love the word places where they put
artificial turf in right
and then and then they put it on the
sidelines and i'm like okay you've got a
temperature gradient you've got a
transition in surface and maybe it's not
wearing out but that's not good for
anyone's health and well-being when it
comes to that's for sure hey carl did i
see a comment from ben yeah yeah ben's
got got a great question i was actually
thinking about this too so ben's comment
is you know we feel like gas exchange
and we read this in textbooks is
important
but difficult to measure and i think to
your point earlier rock you were talking
about it's an art and it's a science
i'm thinking the same thing ben is how
could we measure something like that is
there a test to measure gas exchange and
is that something we could
uh foreseeably use to drive okay if i if
i need more gas exchange here's what i'm
going to do
you mean as a diagnostic tool as a
diagnosis
with lab experiments and you know
platinum electrodes and there's a lot we
can do with bulk density can't we just
assume that there's less air when
there's more bulk dense when the bulk
density is higher yeah i mean we could
do soil physical measurement but that's
not a i was thinking more along if i was
understanding carl's question what can
we do to say yeah we need to do this now
rather than taking a bulk density
measurement and then waiting you know
have it
you know i mean you imagine you could
set up a lab if you wanted to in your
shop or whatever and measure both so
you're saying everybody needs a platinum
electrode right next to their leg hammer
no i'm saying no they don't need that
because i'm not sure you know number one
i just know that all the work that jim
murphy did when we were colleagues at at
um michigan state he was a master's
student i was working on my phd he um
you know those platinum electrodes were
a pain i mean they you know they bend
they do this and you know if the
electrode isn't connected you get false
readings or you don't get a reading at
all or you get some sort of weird little
background the noise on them i felt was
pretty high um
and i you know i want a question
not easy measured not easy to measure
gas exchange or
oxygen diffusion which is you know
essentially an indirect measure of gas
exchange but see here's the thing i keep
going back to and i'm glad ben's here
because he probably saw the conversation
with machete or watch the video because
he wasn't wasn't able to do it live
how is the soil behaving
i don't care about gas exchange i don't
is it sustaining turf and if it's not
sustaining turf uh
does it dr you know is it easy after a
rainfall to see if water infiltrates
right i mean there's there's some
diagnostics you can do i think the the
tougher issue is deciding okay
uh it's not draining well uh it's in the
season
uh it's starting to thin
maybe i'll make a hole
but let me throw something in rock
should i top dress
would you put some sand would you put
some
some compost would you do any soil
amending
as you were thinking about improving
that soil in situ
in the season
okay so let's start with sand right and
you know
if you start saying top dressing you
can't quit okay all right you're going
to be sand top pressing forever and you
were going to use bulk density as your
diagnostic
you put sand on your bulk density
immediately goes up okay okay so so you
so all of a sudden we get rid of a
diagnostic right i mean if that's if
that's the one you want to use right um
and once you i i can't stress it enough
you you know we we've got an example in
in golf you know with push-up greens
where they started top dressing and
people said well we can't do this
anymore or we're going to delay it or
whatever and then they start getting
layering and that creates a problem and
when you look at those greens that have
been top dressed for 40 years 30 years
at least right you know they perform
relatively well but you've created a new
root zone right and and you've done it
over time certainly top dressing has
value um in creating a surface that
doesn't compact as much and you know in
a perfect world all sports fields would
be
flexible enough to have a sand based but
they don't oh and then you know there's
the old msu spartan
sport what is that thing trey created
the spartan system oh yeah with the grid
yeah
that's so great well it actually it
actually started at rutgers harry i
don't care where it started i think it's
so great people name it like the pen
guys they got to name everything pen
something
yeah and if you say pen cross you're
wrong you know
you know you're right but if you say a4
you're wrong because it's you know it's
it's penny okay so it sounds like big no
okay
um
if you're gonna get involved in starting
a sand top dress as a soil amendment
tactic
your opinion is you better think long
and hard uh what about have you seen uh
again not in season but maybe remedial
have you seen the sand slits those big
pieces of equipment that inject the sand
a few inches down on like four or five
inch centers it's a big hopper i think
it's a
i don't know if it's a blade or it's one
of those you know what i'm talking about
it's a copper sand big slits
is that a good interim thing in a gold
mouth
see i think where you have issues where
you know especially gold melts tend to
get depressed you know and then they
then they become
water catchment
right and so if you had extra sand in
there um certainly that would help with
some drainage of some kind even just a
whole i remember um i took care of some
sports fields when i was an uh graduate
student at new mexico state you know
they you know was my first consulting
job right and they had some horribly it
was flood irrigated so i'll give you an
example of how low dec deck it was right
you you opened up a valve and stood
there and watched the water and when you
had four inches on the surface you
closed it down and walked away right um
but you know we we went in and cored
large cores back filled them you know
kind of made like a usga spec green in
that coring hole i mean we're talking
you know six to eight inches in diameter
and those low areas then drained really
well and then we just capped them with
the bermuda grass that we had cut off
when we when we dug the hole right and
it seemed to work relatively well and
and it kept water away from this is a
soccer complex from the gold mouse and
there were some lower areas on the field
because you can imagine it wasn't
leveled 100 even though it was flood
irrigated it still wasn't as level as it
should be because you put three to four
inches on and they irrigate them you
know like every two weeks it's i the
whole idea of flooding a field to
irrigate it is something that's hard for
most people back east to
contemplate so listen we're at the
witching hour here so carl are there
other questions uh before we start to
wrap it up
uh i got nothing nothing left on my end
all right one more then compost
see i don't i don't think there's enough
information you know certainly we
believe compost to be a positive for
soil health if we're going to use that
term you know and and and it does you
know it holds water but it also helps
break up you know increase aggregation
et cetera
property amendments for sure
but i don't know how we get it
an appreciable amount into the profile
um and i just don't think there's enough
there might be data out there that i'm
not aware of i'm not going to say that
it's not out there but i really don't
see the date on what that does
um you know and there's way more data on
crumb rubber right i mean we haven't
really looked into
we haven't really looked into organic
matter
in incorporation especially with you
know we've got all these yard waste
locations we've got availability you
know it does have a cost associated with
it but it's certainly not something that
you have to commit to you wouldn't have
to top dress compost every 7 to 14 days
once you committed to it like you would
with sand so i just i don't i don't know
but i think there would be a positive
effect and i do know of some um sports
drift managers that are putting compost
down
um prior to using a solid not a solid
time traditional solid time but but
something that will push it down into
the profile
off season when there's it's dry enough
that they actually get some shattering
at the same time which helps incorporate
that organic and they seem to think that
it's a a pretty positive practice you
know they said the ter-flex greener i'm
sure that's a nitrogen effect but at
least we're seeing that the nitrogen
you know the nitrification is happening
and that's a soil health thing right so
yeah so i'm not i'm not going to make a
commitment to compost but i see that
there's value there's a potential value
in there that we don't know yet well at
your age
you got to watch how many commitments
you make grandpa so so so so anyway
thanks for joining us rock it's always
good to hear you and see you at least
your outline but i'm sure i know i'm
sorry to everybody but i'm in a
different spot i got and it's sunny here
it's been it's been cloudy for four days
and of course today it's sunny here but
i always always appreciate it
and hope to do it again soon this has
been a production of cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu